اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه الساعه المفصله
من العربيه والتي نبداها بالعناوين
رغم دعوات التهدئه قصف بالطائرات واصوات
مضادات ارضيه في الخرطوم واندرمان
نقابه اطباء السودان تتحدث عن وفاه مرضى
في البيوت بسبب نقص الرعايه الطبيه
وفي اخبارينا ايضا
جينسكي غاضب من تسريب وثائق الفينتاجون عن
بلاده ويؤكد انها تسيء للبيت الابيض
عدنان اسرائيل تهدم منزلين في الضفه احدكم
لعائله الاسيريون
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من العربيه حيث نواصل تغطيه
الشان السوداني المواجهات مستمره لليوم
التاسع عشر على التوالي والخروق تستهدف
الهدنه في طبعتها السادسه في هذا السياق
افاد مراسل العربيه بتجدد الاشتباكات رغم
الهدنه السادسه المعلنه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع واضاف المراسلون الانفجارات سمع في
الخرطوم وام درمان ورصد مراسلنا تحليقا
لطائرات الجيش السوداني في سماء العاصمه
حيث استهدف التمركزات تابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع وفي المقابل رد رده قوات الدعم
السريع بمضادات ارضيه في محيط القصر
الرئاسي
هذا واتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم
السريع بخرق الهدنه في الاحياء السكنيه
واشار الجيش في بيان الى وقوع اعمال نهب
للبنوك والمحلات التجاريه في محيط السد
الهلال بامدرمان لافتا الى هروب اعداد
كبيره من قوه الدعم السريع من اندرمان
باتجاه الغرب وقال الجيش ان السفير الهند
في الخرطوم ابلغ عن اقتحام السفاره وسرقه
ممتلكاتها
قال يوسف عزت مستشار وحمتي للعربيه حنا
قوات الدعم السريع لم توافق بعد على هدنه
مدتها اسبوع كما اكد انهم لا يرفضون الهدى
في حال ضمان التزام بها متهما الجيش
السوداني بخرقها
ينقطع البرهان
وما زلنا نحن اليوم نعيش هدنه معلنه
والطيران يخطف المدنيين ويقصف مواقعنا
لم يتم الالتزام بكل هذه الهدن فمن نستغرق
لاوانه ان
ان ان نقبل الحوتنا لمده اسبوع تبدا بعد
نهايه هذه الهدنه نحن نتعامل مع قوه
وافقنا على هدى بواسطه امريكا بواسطه
السعوديه لم يتم الالتزام على بالهدنه
ليس جهه ما تقول من خلق الهدنه هدى
متتاليه مشاهدينا في السودان كلها باءت
بالفشل ولم تحقق الاهداف المرجوه سواء
بالتوصيل لوقف دائم لاعمال العنف او فتح
ممرات انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي في السودان
ليتم خرقها باستمرار بواسطه تبادل
الاتهامات بالخرق بين طرفي النزاع
مقترح هدنه وموافقه ثنائيه وعهود
بالالتزام ومن ثم ترحيب دولي سيناريو
متطابق تكرر 6 مرات على مدار اسبوعين في
السودان دائما ما ينتهي بالطريقه ذاتها
دون اي نتائج مرجوه مع تبادل طرفي الصراع
الاتهامات بخرقها
اولى المحاولات كانت يوم الثامن عشر من
ابريل لمده 24 ساعه ليتم خرقها باشتباكات
في الخرطوم وهي وليده ساعات اما الثانيه
هدنه قصيره المدى لمده 24 ساعه انتهت قبل
ان تبدا بالطريقه ذاتها التي انتهت فيها
الاولى
هي اول هدنه تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال ايام
عيد الفطر او كما يفترض ذلك انتهت
باشتباكات متفرقه
تمديد للسابقه لمده 72 ساعه في يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسابع والعشرين من
ابريل تمت ببساطه امريكيه لكن الانفجارات
والاشتباكات استمرت خلالهما
واجهت مصاعب قبل تطبيقها حتى فالاشتباكات
كانت تدور جنوبي الخرطوم مع تحليقا لسلاح
الجو السوداني ورد مضادات الطائرات من
قوات الدعم السريع
خروق كانت بشكل اساسي في نقاط حساسه مثل
محيط القياده العامه في الخرطوم والقصر
الرئاسي بالاضافه الى ام درمان وبحري
واقليم دارفور
هدن لا تبصر النور لم تكن اي منها مفتاحا
لفتح باب المفاوضات ووقف القتال في البلاد
ولم تنجح اي منها حتى في السماح بفتح
ممرات انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي باوضاعهم
المترديه عمر العربيه
في السودان الاشتباكات تتواصل رغم الهدن
وضع انساني كارثي وتحذيرات دوليه من
الاسواق اما شرطه السودانيه باتت امام حد
اخر سببه التفلت الامني في البلاد اذ نظمت
حملات لمحاربه الجريمه بهدف بسط هيبه
الدوله وسياده حكم القانون الحملات شملت
في يومها الاول مناطق الفتاح العضليين
وسوق الدخينات وسوق الكلاكله مرورا بابو
ادم والعزوزاب وسوق الشجره بينما نظمت
الحمله في يومها الثاني في شارع الشهيد
ابراهيم شمس الدين ومنطقه السوق الشعبي
بالخرطوم وابو حمامه والمرافق الحيويه اما
حمله اليوم الثالث شملت مناطق امتداد شارع
الرميله مرورا بصك العمله ومخازن السكر
والمنطقه الصناعيه
الحملات حققت اهدافها المطلوبه بمشاركه
القوات المسلحه لتامين الاسواق والمناطق
التجاريه الهامه والمرافق الحيويه
بعد قليل بل تعقد بعد قليل منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي في جده اجتماعا طارئه لمناقشه
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان وذلك بناء على
دعوه من السعوديه التي تتراس القمه
الاسلاميه الحاليه هو اللجنه التنفيذيه
لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي هذا وجدد الامير
العام لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي حسين
ابراهيم طه مناشدته لاطراف النزاع بوقف
اطلاق النار واللجوء الى الحوار واستئناف
العمليه السياسيه
جينا من جده ينضموا لنا مراسله العربيه
سلطان السلمي اهلا بك سلطان وهل بدات
اعمال هذا الاجتماع الطارئ وما ابرز ما
سيناقشه من ملفات في الشان السوداني
اهلا بك بعد نصف ساعه من الان تعقد اللجنه
التنفيذيه بمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
الاجتماعي الطارئ مفتوح العضويه بشان
الاوضاع الراهنه بالسودان بحضور ممثلي
الدول الاعضاء وسوف يبدا الاجتماع بكلمه
لرئيس الاجتماع الدكتور صالح السحيباني
المندوب الدائم للمملكه لدى منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي كذلك يليها كلمه لمعالي الامين
العام لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي السيد حسين
ابراهيم طه وبعد ذلك سوف يكون هنالك
اجتماع مغلق لاستماع لمداخلات الدول
الاعضاء سوف يستمر القرابه الساعه وايضا
من المنتظر ان يخرج هذا الاجتماع ببيان
ختامي يحتوي على جمله من التوصيات المهمه
في سبيل ايجاد حل لهذه الازمه والتعامل مع
التداعيات المختلفه ايضا منذ اندلاع الحرب
في السودان تحركت منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
في كافه الاتجاهات لوقف الصراع العسكري من
خلال التنسيق الثلاثي مع حياه الامم
المتحده وكذلك جامعه الدول العربيه
والاتحاد الافريقي بالاضافه الى المؤسسات
الاقليميه والدوليه والدول الاعظام في
المنظمه دقائق محدوده وسوف يبدا هذا
الاجتماع بحضور 57 ممثل للدول الاعضاء هنا
في منظمه التعاون الاسلامي بمدينه جده
اجنده ومحاور عده سوف يتم نقاشها سوف يتم
نقاش الوضع السياسي في السودان وكذلك ايضا
الوضع الانساني وكيفيه مساعده المجتمع
السوداني وكيفيه ايقاف هذا النزاع المسلح
او الاشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني وكيف هو
الحاله الانساني لهؤلاء المجتمع السوداني
وكذلك المقيمين هنالك في السودان ايضا سوف
يتم الاشاره لعمليات الجداء التي قامت بها
الحكومه السعوديه منذ بدا النزاع المسلح
هناك في السودان نتحدث عن ارقام تصل او
تلامس سته الاف مواطن من اكثر من 100
جنسيه تم اجلائهم من السودان الى مدينه
جده سوف يتم طرح كافه هذه المحاور وهذه
الاجنده على طاوله الاجتماع الذي سوف
يستمر لقرابه ساعه سوف يبدا بكلمتين ومن
ثم سوف هنالك اجتماع مغلق وبعد ذلك سوف
يخرج هذا البيان المنتظر من قبل الدول
الاعضاء ومن قبل رئيس لجنه التنفيذي نعم
اذا سلطان سنكون معك في متابعه لاي تطورات
جيده حول هذا الاجتماع شكرا لك من جده كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي
مشاهدينا معنا من الخرطوم رئيسه تحرير
صحيفه التغيير رشا عوض
طيب اذا ننتقل الى السيد عبد القادر باكاش
من بورسودان الصحفي السوداني في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه وكيف تبدو الاوضاع في
بورسودان الذي تشهد عمليات اجلاء مستمره
للرعايه الاجانب والسوداني ايضا للخروج من
السودان نحو السعوديه والدول العالم
كمنفذه ومعبر وحيد طبعا حاليا معبر رسمي
ما الذي يحدث حاليا في بورسنا وما كيف
يمكن ان الوضع هناك
مرحبا مرحبا بالساده المشاهدين الاعداد
بدات تتزايد رغم ان العجلاء الاجلاء مستمر
بحرا وجوا من مدينه بورسودان الى جده ولا
غيرها من الوجهات لكن عدد التوافد الان
بدا يتزايد من الخرطوم خاصه في الايام
الاخيره
والان استشهد مدينه بورسودان اكتزاز كبير
لعدد من رعايه الدول الذين يفيدون الى
بورسلان ولم يجدوا فرصه للخروج الى
بلدانهم لعدم تواصل الحكوماتهم مع السلطات
السعوديه في السفاره داخل مدينه بورسلان
السفير وكل طاقم السفاره السعوديه الان
مقيمون بشكل مؤقت داخل مدينه بورسودان
وعجلوا مطار لتقديم الخدمات للمقيمين في
السعوديه والرعايه الدول لاجلائهم جميع
الخدمات تقدم لكل من توفرت فيه شروط
الاجلاء لكن حتى الان هناك عدد من
الجنسيات لم يجدوا فرصه
لتواصل هكوماتهم مع الحكومه ليه اقلعهم من
السودان لذلك عدد منهم الان بات موجود في
بورشان مما دفع المنظمات والجمعيات
الخيريه وعدد من الجهات فته يدورها
لاستقبال هؤلاء هؤلاء الوافدين الان عادات
كبيره من ابناء بورسودان استضافوا في دور
الانديه وفي الجمعيات وفي غيرها من المغار
والمنظمات وغيرها المنظمات الوطنيه تستضيف
القادمين من كل انحاء العالم من الخرطوم
في مدينه بورشودان ايضا لاحظنا ان هناك
عدد كبير جدا ايضا من السودانيين
بدانا الى مدينه بورسودان بحثا عن طريق
عامل للخروج الى جمهوريه مصر العربيه او
الى السعوديه او الى اي من دول الخليج
ايضا لاحظنا هناك بعض المقيمين في
الامارات العربيه المتحده لايضا قدموا الى
بورسودان للخروج الى جده ومنها ان شاء
الله الى الامارات اداه كبيره جدا من
الاخوه السوريين واليمنيين والليجيريين
والبنغال والجنود الان موجودين في مدينه
بورسودان وعمليات مستمره ولم تصل اي
معلومات عن اي تواصل جديد فيما يلي
التفرات اليمنيه والسعوديه مع السلطات مع
السلطات السعوديه اليمنيه والسوريه مع
سلطات السعوديه
الانسان الان داخل المدينه
مستقر نسبيا لكن بدا يعني هناك نظر لشوها
الخدمات ونزل في عمليه نقص الغذاء خاصه
بعد التوقف او شبه شلل في الميناء رغم
وصول البوابه السفره التجاريه الى الميناء
لكن لعدم وجود عمل للجمارك الان الامل زي
شبهي متوقف طيب
هذه الساعه الاخباريه
مشاهدينا تتوقع بل يتوقع ان يصل وكيلو
الامين العام المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
للوقوف على عمليات الاجلاء وكان الامين
العام
الى المنطقه في ضوء التدهور السريع الازمه
الانسانيه في السودان يذكر ان لجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر تمكنت من ايصال اول
شحنه مساعدات انسانيه عن طريق الجو الى
مدينه بورسودان مع دخولها الاشتباكات بل
مع دخول الاشتباكات اسبوعها الثالث
الوضع الانساني المتصل بحرب السودان يثير
مخاوف العالم حيث قالت المتحدث باسم البيت
الابيض ان الوضع الانساني في السودان مقلق
ويتوجب على الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع السماح بفتح ممرات لتقديم المساعده
الانسانيه للاهالي
مازلنا قلقين للغايه من الوضع الانساني في
السودان والذي يتدهور بسرعه والعنف الذي
ينتشر بسرعه على طرفي النزاع فتح ممر
انساني للسماح لوكالات الاغاثه بتقديم
المساعده ودعم السودانيين والعاملين في
القطاع الصحي للوصول الى المشافي وتلقي
امدادات الدواء الضروريه
[موسيقى]
طبعا كل المراكز عطله بحاجه الحرب الدائره
الان نحن برامز ظروف
نعمل في هذه الظروف صعبه وعدم امكانيات
الماء موجوده اننا
سحب بعض الادويه والمعدات
هذا وكشف سكرتيره نقابه اطباء السودان
عطيه عبد الله عطيه العربيه عن وجود اكثر
من اثنتي بل 12 الف مريض معرضون للموت
بسبب الاوضاع الصحيه وشددا على ضروره فتح
ممرات امنه لايصال المعونه الطبيه عطيه
يتحدث عن موت مرضى داخل بيوتهم جراء الحرب
الاعداد في ازدياد شديد وهي متواليه
متوقعه بعد يعني تزايد العسكريه سوف يكون
هنالك اكثر من 12 الف مريض معرض للموت
الان نحن لدينا تقارير من ان هنالك عدد من
المرضى توفي داخل منازلهم لانه في
المستشفيات وفي المنازل يشكل مشكله كبيره
جدا في ظل عدم وصول هذه المعينات سوف
يتعرض 12,000 للموت نحن قلناها وكررناها
ان طرفي الصراع في السودان تركوا الشعب
السوداني امام خيارين اما الموت بالرصاص
او الموت بالمرض فلل بسيطه فقط فتح ممرات
امنه بالتاكيد سوف نصل الى هذه المستشفيات
سوف يستطيع الداعمين الوصول وتوصيل
معيناتهم بالتاكيد سوف يعني يتكاثف الجميع
في في هذه الازمه
التقارير لوزاره الصحه السودانيه كشف ايضا
تسجيل ست اصابات جديده بولايه الخرطوم
وحاله وفاه واحده بولايه بولايه وسط
دارفور ليقترب بذلك عدد الاصابات التراكمي
من خمسه الاف اصابه وخمسمائه
في جميع انحاء البلاد واوضح التقرير ان
الهدوء يسود كافه الولايات الخرطوم وسط
دارفور لكن الجهات الطبيه تواصل تسجيل
اصابات ووفيات نتيجه الحرب القائمه
وفي محاوله لتخفيف عباء القتال الداخلي
بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الذي يدور
في السودان منذ اكثر من اسبوعين يخاطر
مستشفى خاص في ام درمان بفتح ابوابه لخدمه
نساء الحوامل واجراء ولاده دون مقابل مادي
وفي ظل ظروف امنيه وانسانيه توصف
بالكارثيه
ترد المؤسسات الصحيه
[موسيقى]
يرافق استمرار القتال في السودان
لكن مستشفى خاصا في ام درمان
ينجح بفتح ابوابه لخدمه النساء الحوامل
مجانا
في ظل شبه كامل للامن
وارتفاع اثمان المستلزمات في السوق
السوداء
اكثر من عشره اضعاف السعر الحقيقي
320 عمليه ولاده قيصريه اجراها منذ اندلاع
القتال
فيما تقول نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان
اكثر من خمسين مستشفى بالخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل
وتحذيراته من انهيار القطع الصحي تتواصل
من الخرطوم مشاهدينا تنضم الينا رئيسه
تحرير صحيفه التغيير رشا عوض اهلا بك سيد
رشا معنا الساعه الاخباريه اذا نتحدث عن
هدنه سادسه ولا مؤشرات حتى الان على
احترامها من قبل الطرفين الجيش والدعم
السريع الى ما يعد ذلك في تقديرك
قناه العربيه
السبب في ان اي هدنه مهدده بان تكون
كسابقاتها هو ان كلا الطرفين الان يريد
تحقيق انتصارات ميدانيه
وخصوصا ان الصراع العسكري مش حول مواقع
استراتيجيه منها القياده العامه للجيش
والقصر الجمهوري والاذاعه والتلفزيون
ومطار الخرطوم
وبالتالي متوقع ان لا يحترم الطرفان
الهدنه لحسابات عسكريه
السبب الثاني وهو الاخطر هو انه هناك طرف
ثالث يقف خلف هذه الحرب ويديرها في الخفاء
هم فلول النظام البائد من الاسلامويين
هؤلاء خطهم الاستراتيجي تصعيد الحرب
والانحدار الى الفوضى الشامله وبالتالي هم
من يحرضون على القتال بل واما العناصر
الاسلامويه في الجيش تعلن في وسائل
الاعلام انها لم تسمع بهدنه وان ليس هناك
تفاوض مع ان قياده الجيش تتحدث عن تفاوض
فليس هناك مركز موحد للقرار وللخطاب
الاعلامي حتى داخل الجيش وبالتالي نتوقع
ان تلحق هذه الخدمه بسابقاتها طيب يعني ما
هي مصلحه فلان نظام السابقه كما شرطي سيدي
رشا في استمرار وضع القائم حاليا يعني هل
الرغبه فقط هي في ازاحه محمد حمدان ان
هناك اسباب اخرى
هم يستميتون في ازاحه الدعم السريع بالحرب
لانه قد حذروا من ذلك قبل الحرب قبل الحرب
كانوا يقولون انهم لن يسمحوا لاي عمليه
سياسيه في السودان ان تكتمل وام صبركم نفد
وقيادات اسلاميه معروفه قالت انهم قادرين
على حمل السلاح
لوقف الاتفاق الاطاري واصلا العقليه
الانقلابيه هي مسيطره على هذا التنظيم منذ
استيلائهم على السلطه في 30 يونيو 89 الان
يعيدون ذات السيناريو يتوقعون انهم يمكن
ان يحققوا مكاسب من الفوضى ويعودون
للسيطره على البلاد مجددا ولكن الواقع
يقول اننا الان نتجه الى
نبضي في طريق مسدود لا منتصره فيه ومعاناه
الشع ب تتفاقم
طيب في الدرجه تفضل بالبقاء معي ساعود
اليكي من جديد في سياق هذه الساعه
الاخباريه
اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان ان وزير
الخارجيه سامح شكري ناقشات تمديد وتوسيع
وقف اطلاق النار في السودان خلال اتصال
هاتفي جرى بينهما امس الثلاثاء وقال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الوزيرين اتفقا ان الوزيرين اتفقا على
مواصله المشاوره الوثيقه بين واشنطن
والقاهره فيما يتعلق بالجهود الجاريه
لتحقيق وقف دائم للاعمال القتاليه في
السودان
هذا واكد المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه
مع طرفي النزاع في السودان مشيرا الى ان
بلاده ملتزمه بالدعوه لوقف دائم لاطلاق
النار
ليس لدي اي ارتباطات دبلوماسيه محدده
لقراءتها لكننا بالطبع بقينا على اتصال
الوثيق مع البرهان وحميدتي من خلال
مستويات مختلفه هنا في وزاره الخارجيه
والتزمنا في الدعوه الى وقف اطلاق النار
وتمديد على امل الوصول الى وقف دائم وعملي
للعمل الادائيه وهذا يعيدنا الى الانسجام
مع اراده الشعب السوداني وهي حكومه
الانتقاليه متجذره في الديمقراطيه
نشرت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه بيانها على
صفحتها الرسميه على موقع تويتر استنكرت
فيه اقتحام مبنى الملحقي الثقافي السعودي
في السودان من قبل مجموعه مسلحه خربت
الاجهزه والكاميرات واستولت على بعض
الممتلكات وعطلت الانظمه وخوادم الملحقيه
الخارجيه السعوديه دعت الى احترام حرمه
البعثات الدبلوماسيه في السودان والى
معاقبه الجنح
في ملف الاجلاء اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه
عن عدد ما تم اجلؤه من السودان حتى الان
والذي بلغ
5629 شخصا من رعايه اكثر من 100 جنسيه
وقالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان عدد المواطنين
الذين تم اجلائهم الى السودان بلغ 239
اخرهم وصل مساء الثلاثاء علامه سفينه
جلاله الملك الرياض الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده
اتواجد حاليا على متن سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض وهي الرحله الخامسه عشر منذ بدا
عمليات الاجلال من ميناء بورت سودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحري سوف ناخذكم في
جوله خاصه لشاشه العربيه كما نشاهد الان
بدات عمليات الانزال بعد ان وصلت هذه
السفينه من ميناء بورت سودان في رحله
استغرقت قرابه العشره الساعات من ميناء
بورد سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده على متن هذه السفينه 220 راكبا من
خمسه جنسيات
نتحدث عن 91 من الجنسيه الامريكيه و14
مواطن السعودي وثلاثه كنديين واثنان من
جنوب السودان وواحد من الجنسيه السودانيه
ايضا نتحدث انه اعداد كبيره تصل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده منذ بدء عمليات
الاجلاء خلال الايام الماضيه نتحدث عن
ارقام اجم تتجاوز الخمسه الاف
مواطن اجنبي من مئه جنسيه تم اجلائهم من
ميناء بورسودان الى جده عبر قاعه الملك
فيصل البحريه او حتى الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه وكذلك الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
اعداد كبيره من الرعايه يتوافدون يوما بعد
يوم وتزداد الاعداد بشكل ملحوظ مع عمليه
مع كل عمليه اجلاء ايضا ومتوقع وصول سفينه
مدنيه تجاريه سعوديه على متنها اعداد
تلامس الفين شخص يوم
ظهر يوم غدا
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه في
افاده صحفيه امس قال ان القنصليه
الامريكيه في مدينه جده السعوديه استقبلت
وقدمت خدماتها لاكثر من 350 شخصا من
المواطنين الامريكيين والحاصلين على
اقامات دائمه في الولايات المتحده والذين
افروا من السودان في ظل الاوضاع العسكريه
الراهنه التي تشهدها البلاد
بدورها قالت الحكومه البريطانيه في بيان
ان على الرعايه البريطانيين الراغبين في
مغادره السودان التوجه الى فندق كورال في
بورسودان حيث سمي المتوقع ان تغادر رحلات
اضافيه البلاد اليوم
هذا واعلن المغرب من جهته نهايه عمليات
الاجلاء للمواطنين المغاربه من السودان
حيث تم اجلاء 572 شخصا علمتني اربع رحلات
جويه
على سلام والحمد لله كله عن طريق السفاره
وجزاهم الله خير والله ينصر سيدنا والحمد
لله على سلامتنا اقول الله يحفظ ملكنا
وربنا يديه طوله العمر ان شاء الله احنا
طلعنا من حاجه
جهنم شعور زوين الحمد لله على سلامه
الجميع والحمد لله الاحساس بالامان الحمد
لله على كل شيء
يعني وحنا جايين في الكار عاد وصلنا ان
شاء الله للطياره وجينا الحمد لله بخير
وكل شيء يعني داز امن والحمد لله على خير
وصلنا بسلام راحنا فرحانين الحمد لله
وكنشكر سيدنا زعما اللي بادر معنا هكا
ووقف معانا
وتوصلنا المغرب في امان
مشاهدينا العود مره اخرى الى الصحفي عبد
القادر باكاش اهلا بك عبد القادر من جديد
وكنت تتحدث ايضا من خلال محادثتك معنا في
المقابله الاولى عن شوح في التموينات
تعانيهم مدينه بورسودان المكتظه بعدد
كبيره من الرعايه الاجانب وبين المواطنين
السودانيين ايضا
هل هناك خيارات واضحه لحكومه ولايه البحر
الاحمر للتعاطي مع هذه الازمه
متوفره داخل مدينه بورسودان لكن هناك
مخاوف من نقص هذه الامدادات خاصه اذا
توقفت حركه الملاح البحريه خاصه بعد اعلان
شركه
اكبر الخطوط المياه البحريه التي تستفيد
الى مدينه بورسودان توقف القاء التسلم
الحجوزات للسودان بالاضافه الى توقف حركه
العمل في الجمارك بسبب توقف شبكات الاتصال
داخل الجمارك في الخرطوم وايضا هناك يعني
انخفاض واضح في طاقه العمل للبنوك فروع
البنوك والمصارف في مدينه برشلونه كل هذه
العوامل نتوقع ان تشحن بشكل مباشر في
تناقش السلع الاستراتيجيه
والاكتزاز هذا يؤثر على المواد الغذائيه
داخل المدينه
[موسيقى]
التهريب والمضاربه في السرعه الاستهلاكيه
وشددت العقوبات على الذين يتعاملون في
السلع الغذائيه وفي المعروقات وغيرها حتى
الان جميع الجهات تتعاون بشكل كبير لكن
اجمل
الى المدينه كبير جدا خلال اليومين
الماضيين خاصه مع اعلان اي هدنه الان بدا
يخرج كل الذين يستطيعون الخروج من ولايه
الخرطوم الى مدينه بورسودان باعتبار على
الوجهه الاولى في الانجلاء داخل السودان
الان البقيه
ممرات بحريه بريه المنافذ البريه الان في
شمال السودان في شرق السودان ايضا تفيد
اليها لكن الطاقه الكبرى الى مدينه
[موسيقى]
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات